[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ال سيئه
بعاصف الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الحمدانيه في
نينوى شماليه العراق واجواء الحداد على
ضحايا الحريق الذي اندلع خلال حفل زفاف
وراحه ضحيه نحو مئه قتيل
وهذه الصور تريدنا من ميامي في اعقاب رحيل
السفير الفرنسي الى باريس بعد شهر من
مطالبه المجلس العسكري في النيجر له
بالمغادره
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
عدد ضحايا حريق الحمدانيه بالعراق يقترب
من المئه
تشييع الضحايا وايقاف عدد من المتهمين
والسلطات تعزو الكارثه لاستخدام العاب
ناريه خلال حفل الزفاف والناطق باسم
الحكومه يقر في حديث للجزيره لوجود تقصير
في متابعه معايير السلامه
سفير فرنسا في النيجر يعود الى باريس بعد
شهر من مطالبه المجلس العسكري له
بالمغادره ومكروه يؤكد مواصله الجهود
لاستعاده النظام الدستوري في نيامي وفي
جولاته الافريقيه وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ينتقد الانقلابات ويقول ان القاره تحتاج
الى مؤسسات فعاله يقودها مدنيون
[موسيقى]
في خضم حراك غربي بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
ترحيب امريكي بقبول اذربيجان بفكره نشر
مراقبين بشان عمليات النزوح من كاراباغ
وموسكو تدعو قاده ارمينيا لتذكر مسمته
مصير الدول الحليفه للولايات المتحده
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا افاق العلاقات بين ارمينيا
وروسيا بالنظر الى ما تشهده من توتر ملحوظ
على خلفيه ملف كهرباء فضلا عن تردد دعوات
في ارمينيا لتخفيض مستوى العلاقات مع
موسكو لاستطاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي اي منح
تتخذه علاقات موسكو في المستقبل المنظور
ثلاثه وستون في المئه قالوا ان العلاقات
ستتجه الى الفتور مع توجه ارمني غربا
37%
العلاقات بين موسكو على وضعها
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودويا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
الحرب في السودان
وتداعياتها تحصد ارواح مئات الاطفال وتضع
الملايين منهم على حافه الخطر بسبب الفقر
وكثره الامراض
[موسيقى]
اذا فاجعه انسانيه جديده في العراق
ضحاياها يناهزون المئتين بين قتيلا ومصاب
اثر حريقا بقاعه زفاف في منطقه الحمدانيه
بمحافظه نينوى وشماليه البلاد وقال الناطق
باسم وزاره الصحه العراقيه ان عدد القتلى
بلغ اربعه وتسعين وتجاوز عدد المصابين 100
شخص اضاف في تصريح للجزيره ان هذه الحصيله
ليست نهائيه بسبب وجود العديد من الحالات
التي وصفها بالحرجه في مستشفيات الموصل
هدوء هذه الخيمه لا يعكس ما يعتمد في صدور
الجالسين فيها فقد سامان امه في الحريق
وفقد معها ولديه وزوجته في دقائق معدودات
[موسيقى]
داخل البيت لم تتمالك هؤلاء النسوه انفسهم
ففي هذه الدوابيت فضلا عن جثامين الاحبه
ما يذكر بالفاجعه كتب لبعضهن النجاه من
حريق الحمدانيه بعجوبه لكن الاسى على من
رحلوا اقوى واشد
شويه نار جميل القاعه
شغل الدقائق كلها احترقتها ناري اشتعلت مد
تقدر لا تطب لا تطلع ما تقدر قرب البيت من
قاعه الاعراس المحترقه ينكؤ جراح العائله
وينذرها ان النسيان سيكون صعبا وربما بقدر
صعوبه تلك الليله العصيبه حدث كل شيء
بسرعه شراره فنار فحريق التهم كل شيء
تاركا المئات بين قتيل وجريح ومصاب بصدمه
يصعب ان تشفى
تشير الروايه الرسميه الى ان السبب ثلاثي
الاضلاع مواد بناء رديئه قابله للاشتعال
واحتفال بالعاب ناريه وغياب مخارج الطوارئ
وصفه متكامله للكارثه جميع التعزيز
ات من الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه والصحيه
وحاليا الوضع مسيطر عليه في داخل المستشفى
بالكامل شكلنا لجنه تحقيقيه لتحديد
ملابسات الحادث والمقصرين وراح ينالون
جزاهم العادل
نجمه مركزيه مشتركه من قبل
الاستخبارات والدفاع المدني والشرطه
على اجواء البلده غمامه حزن ممزوج بالغضب
فما حدث يقول سكانها كان بالامكان تفاديه
لولا انتشعوا وغياب القانون والمساءله
ستبقى هذه القبور شهده على يوم ماساوي في
ذاكره الحمدانيه يوم لم ترى البلده مثيره
له في تاريخها ويامل سكانها الا تذهب
ارواح الضحايا وان تستخلص عبر الكارثه
تفاديا لتكرارها
قال الناطق باسم الحكومه العراقيه باسم
العوادي ان تقصيرا قد حدث بالفعل في ملف
مراقبه شروط المطلوبه لسلامه المباني
والمؤسسات اضاف العواد في حديث للجزيره ان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي امر باعاده النظر في
هذا الملف
هناك تقصير يقع على عاتق بعض المؤسسات في
المتابعه لكن هذا التقصير هو كما تعرفون
يعني يتحرك من الدائره القضيق بالنهايه
تحال القضيه الى مجموعه مراقبين في
البلديات وهؤلاء المراقبين طبعا يتعاطون
مع هذه المخازن
وفق صغرها صغر حجمها او كبرها قلت هذا
الحاله الشعبيه او الحاله الروحيه احيانا
كثيره هي تنعكس على هذا الاداء المهم كان
واحد من اهم توجيهات لسيد رئيس الوزراء
اليوم هو الرجوع مره اخرى الى هذا الملف
تجديد اجراءات السلامه والتحرك على كل
المباني
وقد اعلن مجلس القضاء الاعلى في العراق ان
قاضي التحقيق المختص اصدر التوجيهات
للاجهزه الامنيه بالقبض على المتسببين في
الحريق واكد بيان للمجلس اعتقال عدد من
العاملين في قاعه المناسبات خصوصا
المشرفين على نصب الالعاب الناريه التي
كانت السبب الرئيس في اندلاع الحريق واوضح
البيان ان احاطه سقف القاعه باقمشه سريعه
للشعال كان سببا ايضا في الحريق اضافه الى
عدم وجود مخرج بعد غلق الباب الرئيسي
للقاعه واوضح ان صاحب القاعه وبقيه
المتهمين الهاربين سلموا انفسهم الى
الاجهزه الامنيه في اربيل وتم نقلهم الى
مدينه الموصل لتدوين اقوالهم قضائيا
ينضم الينا من الموصل وزير الداخليه
العراقي عبد الامير الشمري مرحبا بك سيد
الوزير وتعازينا لكم ما اخر المعلومات
التي توصلت اليها التحقيقات بشان هذه
الكارثه
شكرا اهلا وسهلا بكم الصحيه لكم ولكل
المشاهدين في قناتكم
الحقيقه لا بد بدايتها من نعزي كل اهلنا
وشعبنا بهذه الفاجعه الاليمن التي راح
ضحيتها اكثر تقريبا 94 شهيد واكثر من 100
مصاب
قسم منهم غادر داخل مستشفيات في الموصل
وفي اربيل
حقيقه التحقيقات
وتحقيق باشراف في شخصيه اشراف شخصيا
الان يسير ولحد هذه اللحظه
كل المتهمين في القضيه في قبضه العداله
حاليا
الشخص اللي صاحب القاعه
وايضا الاشخاص اللي كانوا يديرون موضوع
الالعاب الناريه داخل القاعه
عليهم
عشره من العاملين في
القاعده تم توقيفه لازم يجري تحقيقات
المقصرين
بهذه القاعه من
السلطات المحليه في القضاء
ومستمرين بالتحقيق وسيتم انجاز تحقيق
واعلانه خلال 20 ساعه القادمه كم عدد
الذين جرى اعتقالهم سيد الوزير
14 شخص تم اعتقادهم وتوقفهم لحد هذه
اللعبه بالنسبه للمسؤولين بشكل مباشر عما
حدث في حفل الزفاف ولكن ماذا عن التقصير
الاكبر والاوسع فيما يتعلق بالسلطات
المولجه بمتابعه
ان مثل هكذا مؤسسات
حريصه على السلام العامه
طبعا بالتاكيد
في اجراءات السلامه والامان في القاعه
اللي موجوده
من المواد سريعه الاشتعال وكل تفاصيلها في
داخل القاعه من السقوف والجدران هي مواد
سريعه الاشتعال وكذلك سقف البنايه ليس من
البناء
يعني
السقوف الوقتيه لذلك خلال دقائق صار
الحريق وانهيار السحور على الموجودين في
القاعه كان عدد الموجودين في قاعه تقريبا
اكثر من 900 شخص سيد الوزير مثل هكذا
قاعات
يعني
ان يتم اقامه زفاف فيها وان تستقبل مئات
الاشخاص يفترض انها تحصل على تراخيص من هي
الجهه التي اعطت الترخيص
لهذه القاعه او للمسؤولين عن هذه القاعه
رغم انها تخالف السلامه العامه وحسب ما
فهمنا ايضا القوانين العراقيه في هذا
المجال
في ارض متجاوز عليها المعلومات الاوليه
وحاليا يتم يعني التحقيق بخصوص من اعطى
الموافقه
وكذلك الفحص اللي يجري بخصوص المواد اللي
داخله في بناء هذه القاعه على انه هي مواد
رصينه ام مواد يعني سريعه الاشتعال لذلك
من تحقيق جانب من اتجاه اصحاب القاعه وما
تم يعني اللي يسببوا هذا الحديث هو
التقصير اللي حصل وراح يكون يعني عقابهم
رابع
جزاهم العادل ولكن هل جرى اعتقال احد من
بين المعتقلين من من هم يفترض ان يكونوا
ان يراقبوا مثل هكذا اعمال
وتصدر مذكرات التوقيت
طيب سيدي الوزير كيف يمكن ان تطمئن
المواطنين اليوم الاهالي الذين فقدوا
افراد من عائلاتهم ان مثل هكذا حوادث لن
تتكرر في العراق في المستقبل
بالتاكيد طبعا هناك يعني اجراءات سيتم
العمل بها وهذا اجراءات ضمن غلق هذه
الاماكن العامه اللي مبنيه بالمواد بناء
سريعه
الوقتيه
واجراءات
الدفاع المدني مع الاجزاء الامنيه الاخرى
وكذلك
من قبل الساده المحافظين باعتبارهم رؤسائم
للجانب الفرعيه للدفاع المدني في
المحافظاتهم
لهذه المحلات
وتم متابعتها بشكل تفصيل ويوم من قبل يعني
الاختصاصي الموجودين في مديريه الدفاع متى
يفترض ان تدخل هذه الاجراءات حيز التنفيذ
بكل المحافظات بانه يعملون
بفحص هذه الاماكن الاماكن العامه
وتاشيرها ويتم غلقها حاليا
بكجره اولي ما رسالتكم
للاهالي اهالي الضحايا اليوم طبعا لا شيء
يساوي فقدان الارواح والحياه والاحبه ولكن
ما نوع التعويض ربما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه
السلطات في العراق
هناك تعويض يعني
راح يتم لذوي الضحايا وراح نعرض امام مجلس
الوزراء الموافق عليه لكن من قبلهم انه كل
من قصر وكل من ساهم في هذه الكارثه لن
يفلتني
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الامير الشمري وزير
الداخليه العراقي ضيفنا من الموصل شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى تطوراتي في النيجر اذ اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه عوده سفير باريس في
نيامه وتزامل ذلك مع تجديد الرئيس الفرنسي
التزامه بمواصله العمل من اجل عوده النظام
الدستوري الى النيجر وفي السياق نفسه
يتحدث وزير الدفاع الامريكي بان القاره
الافريقيه كلها بحاجه الى مؤسسات يقودها
مدني
لم يعد السفير الفرنسي هنا يترك سلوفان
مقر عمله في النيجر بعد شهر من مطالبه
المجلس العسكري له بالمغادره يصل باريس
بعد ان كانت رفضت ما وصفته بالرضوخ لمطالب
المجلس العسكري في النيجر بحلول نهايه
العام ستنهي فرنسا وجودا عسكريا في النيجر
استمر عقودا قبل وبعد الاستقلال في النيجر
تمركزت لاعوام قوه فرنسيه من اكثر من الف
جندي في قاعده جويه متقدمه في العاصمه
نيامي لكن النيجر تستضيف قوه اجنبيه
متنوعه تتمركز قوات امريكيه في قاعدتين
جويتين تضمان 1200 جندي لالمانيا هناك
110 جنود في عاصمه النيجر بالاضافه الى
250 جنديا ايطاليا الى جانب اقل من 100
جندي تابعين للاتحاد الاوروبي
لا مشكله مع هذه القوات يقول النا باسم
المجلس العسكري في البلاد ولن يطلب منها
الانسحاب الاهم بالنسبه للمجلس العسكري
انه لا يريد قوات بديله للجنود الفرنسيين
المغادرين وسط كل هذه القرارات المهمه في
تاريخ النيجر يجدد ماكرون دعمه عوده
النظام الدستوري في النيجر وفي السياق
نفسه يتحدث وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي يرى
ان القاره الافريقيه كلها بحاجه الى
مؤسسات يقودها مدنيون
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بدعم السياسات
الحكوميه التي تعمل على تعزيز السلام
والامن والحكم الديمقراطي ففي جميع انحاء
القاره راينا مستبدين يقوضون الانتخابات
الحره والنزيهه ويمنعون الانتقال السلميه
للسلطه لكن كلام الوزير الامريكي لم يقلق
المسؤولين العسكريين في النيجر تبقي
واشنطن نفسها بمنئا عن توتر حكام النيجر
الجدد مع فرنسا اذ يبدو ان الازمه بالفعل
محصوره بين النيامي بحلتها الجديده وباريس
بتاريخها الاستعماري هكذا يبدا العد
التنازلي للوجود الفرنسي في النيجر بعد
عقود من الاستعمار وما لحقه من تعاون
سياسي وعسكري وصل حد التحالفات
الاستراتيجيه
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
مراسل الجزيره لطفي المسعودي ومعنا من
نيام مراسل الجزيره فضل عبد الرزاق مرحبا
بكما لطفي المسعودي ماذا في اخر التصريحات
والمواقف الصادره عن القاده في فرنسا بعد
عوده السفير
سي اخر
يعني المستجدات في فرنسا واستقبال وزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كولونا لسفير
بلادها في النيجر سيلفاناتي الذي شكرته هو
والطاقم الدبلوماسي المرافق له على ما
وصفتها بالجهود الجباره التي مثلوها في
خدمه فرنسا في ظروف وصفتها ببالغه الصعوبه
هذه الظروف بالغه الصعوبه هي من بين
الماخذ التي
يعني
يصموا بها
المعارضه تسمو بها المعارضه هنا في فرنسا
حكومه ايمانويل ماكرون وتقول انها اخفقت
في التعامل مع هذه الازمه بالذاتشي
ويشككون في جدوى ما اقدمت عليه هذه
الحكومه من الدخول في شهرين من الشد
والجذب مع ان التصميم كان واضحا من مجلس
العسكريه الحاكم في ميامي بضروره مغادره
سفير وكذلك مغادره القوات الامريكيه حتى
وان كانت الاراء الاكثر مغالاتا تعتبر ان
المسؤول الاول عن تدهور سوره فرنسا وتهديد
مصالحها في المنطقه هي روسيا الذي
يتهمونها بنشر بروباغاندا معاديه لفرنسا
تستهدف ليس فقط مصالحها الدبلوماسيه
والعسكريه وانما كذلك
مصالحها الاقتصاديه ويقولون يجب الانتباه
هنا الى اخر رساله ارسلها المجلس العسكري
الحاكم في نيامي طرح مساله ضروره او يعني
هنالك بعض الاشاعات الرائجه يقولون ان
المجلس العسكري وراءها ضروره سحب الترخيص
من شركه اورانو المنتجه لليورانيوم لان
هذه المساله بالفعل هي مساله استراتيجيه
بالنسبه للمصالح الفرنسيه كما نعلم فرنسا
70% من كهربائها بالاعتماد على اليورانيوم
وربع احتياجات الاتحاد الاوروبي دوله
مجتمعه تاتي من النيجر
المواقف الاخرى تقول لا يجب تحميل حكومه
ماكرون جميع المسؤوليه على الاخفاق والفشل
في التعامل مع ملف النيجر وكذلك ملف
افريقيا
ويحملون الحكومات التي سبقت هذه المستعمله
هذه
الاخفاقات ويقولون ان ارثا استعماريا
ثقيلا لم يتم تصفيته بالطريقه المثلى
وانما مالت اليه الاوضاع في النيجر وقبلها
مالي وبوركينا فاسو ونتيجه حتميه للتاخر
في معالجه هذا الموضوع ويطالبون حكومه
ماكرون بالوفاء بوعده بطرح ملف المصالح
الفرنسيه في افريقيا للنقاش في البرلمان
مثلما وعد ذلك بذلك سابقا ومنذ اسابيع في
رساله وجهها الى رؤساء الكتل الحزبيه في
البرلمان
في باريس فضل عبد الرزاق كيف تتفاعل هذه
المساله خروج السفير بعد اسابيع من قول
فرنسا انه لن يخرج وتعهد فرنسا بسحب جميع
قواتها من النيجر كيف يتفاعل هذا الامر في
ميامه
هنا في نيامي ينظرون الى الاخبار التي
وصلت وتبين ان السفير الفرنسي قد غادر
بالفعل اراضي النيجر
والقرار الذي اتخذه الرئيس ايمانويل
بمغادره سحب ومغادره القوات الفرنسيه ايضا
من النيجر على ان هذا النجاح
للجهود التي بذلت من المناصرين للمجلس
العسكري وكذلك ما يقولون انه صموط للمجلس
العسكري على التداعيات وكذلك على الضغوط
التي مرست عليه بالغاء قراره بوقف
الاتفاقيات العسكريه والامنيه مع فرنسا
الجمعيات المناصره للمجلس العسكري بعضها
كانت قد اسست قبل الايقاعها بالرئيس محمد
وبازوم وهذه الجم لا تقف عند المطالبه فقط
بمغادره القوات الفرنسيه من النيجر انما
يقولون ان معظم المصالح الاقتصاديه لفرنسا
ايضا اخذت بطريقه غير قانونيه ولذلك فانها
تتحدث عن انه يجب على النيجر ان تلقي تلقي
الاتفاقيات المنظمه للعمله في النيجر وهي
عمله الفرنك السيفاء يعتبرونها ايضا رمز
للنفوذ الاقتصادي الفرنسي وهم يتحدثون
الان مثل حركه
62 تتحدث عن ان رخصه استغلال الشركه
الفرنسيه
لمناجم اليورانيوم هنا في النيجر ايضا لم
تحصل هذه الشركه على الرخصه بطريقه
قانونيه وعلى السلطه في النيجر طلب الرئيس
هذه المنظمه طالب المجلس العسكري بالغاء
رخصه الشركه الفرنسيه
الجمعيات الاخرى التي اسست بعد الاطاحه
بالرئيس محمد بازون فهذه الجمعيات تقف
مسانده للمجلس العسكري وتقول ان كل
القرارات التي اتخذها هذا المجلس هي
قرارات شرعيه باعتبارهم ممثلا للشعب وانه
تامل بان تراجع الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون عن
قراره برفض الغاء الاتفاقيات سيؤدي ايضا
الى فتح مجال للتفاوض مع بلدان ايكوس ورفع
العقوبات ومن ثم بدا مرحله انتقاليه
بالسقف الذي حدده رئيس المجلس العسكري وهو
ثلاث سنوات شكرا جزيلا لكم ما فضل عبد
الرزاق من نيامي ولطف المسعودي من باريس
معنى منه الباحث والمحلل السياسي والمختص
في الشان الافريقي سيد احمد ولد بابا
مرحبا بك سيد احمد ولد بابا ما دلالات
وصول الازمه الى الى هنا خروج السفيره
الفرنسيه من نيام بعد اسابيع من التعنت
الفرنسي في ذلك
وحديث ماكرون بعد ان خرج السفير عن
استمرار دعم الرئيس محمد بازوم
هي تشير بشكل اساسي الى ان الجهود
الفرنسيه في عاده الرئيس السابق للنيجر
محمد بازون قد وصلت الى طريق مسدود او في
طريقها الى الوصول الى طريق مسدود الرئيس
الفرنسي كابر وحاول ان لا يخرج من النيجر
وان يتعامل مع الحكومه الجديده بقدر من
التجاهل مراهنا على جهود الاكواز في اعاده
النظام الدستوري الى البلاد بالقوه بعد ان
رفض العسكريون اعادته بالتفاوض ولكن بعد
مرور الشهر على الازمه السياسيه في النيجر
والمطالبه برحيل السفير الفرنسي بات
الرئيس مضطر تحت الضغط الداخلي في فرنسا
وتحت ايضا الضغط
واصرار الحكومه الجديده في النيجر على
رحيل السفير الفرنسي وتقويض الوجود
العسكري في ثالث دوله في افريقيا بهذا
الشكل غير المسبوق ان يسحب السفينه
والحفاظ على سلامته ثانيا تجنبا لمزيد من
التدهور العلاقه بفرنسا ثالثا الرئيس
الفرنسي وجد نفسه في ازمه في الملف النيجر
لا يمكن ان يتم حسمه من قبل فرنسا وحده
الامريكيه 100 بنفسها على نفسه
لا ترى
على لسان الرئيس الفرنسي يقول انها مستمره
في جهودها مع ايكواس ودول اوروبيه لعوده
نظام بازو هل هذا واقعي هل يمكن بعد كل
هذا الوقت اعاده بازون
اعتقد ان هذا غير ممكن الرئيس الفرنسي
حاول ان يكابر وحاول ان يدفع لدول الاقواس
الى مواجهه عسكريه مع الحكام الجدد في
النيجره لكن التردد الذي لمسناه في اكثر
من دوله داخل القاره السمراء وخصوصا دول
الساحه التي
ترا ان اي تصرف تجاه النيجر وتهديد
عرقله بالاساس تحرك الفرنسيين ودول
الاقواس اللي طاح عسكريه من الحكام الجدد
النيجر وبالتالي ولا يريد ان ينزل من
الشجره بهذا الشكل السلس يحاول ان يقول
الراي العام الداخلي بان دعمه للحكومه
الشرعيه في النيجر مازال مستمر وانه
يتشاور مع امازون قبل اتخاذ قرار وان
الحكام العسكريين ليسوا من طرد السفير
النيجر وانما هو من استدعاه لتحقيق مصالح
فرنسيه وللحفاظ على سلامته ولكن اعتقد ان
فرنسا بعد انسحبت السفيرها من النيجر
وسعاده وستسحب الجنود الفرنسيه من النيجر
ستكون امكانيه
تقويض الحكم العسكري الحالي في النيجر من
صعوبه بمكان لا تمسح الامريكيه هي من
يمتلك ف نيا وعسكريا القدره على هذا الحل
العسكري وبالتالي هي نافسي كما قلت لك عن
التدخل في ملف النيجر وبالتالي بقيه
الاطراف ستلجا اما الى المبادره الجزائريه
واما الى حل اخر يتم عن طريق السؤال
الفرنسيه ما الخيارات الفرنسيه الان في
ضوء هذه الازمه هل يعني كيف يمكن ان تتطور
العلاقه الان مع النيجر في ضوء الحكم
الجديد
الخيارات الفرنسيه هي خيارات صعبه هي
تحاول تخفيف الخسائر الفرنسيه في الساحل
بشكل
يحفظ
الفرنسيهم بعض المصالح ولكن اعتقد ان
العلاقه مع النيجر ومع بعض دول المنطقه
وصلت الى طريق الى عوده الخيارات المتاحه
الان تبادر الدول الموجوده في الكواز
والتي اعلنت مواقف ايجابيه من ما حصل في
النيجر الى طرح حل التفاوضي يمكن من
العوده الى النظام الدستوري او القبول
بالمبادره الجزائريه التي طرحت او البحث
عن حل بالتوافق مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بوصفها ذاع الاساسي في المنطقه
لا يمكن تجاوزه اما ان تفرض فرنسا حلها
الذي كانت تريد بعوده محمد بازون الحكام
العسكريين فهذا امر مستبعد فرنسا الان
معنيه بان تحافظ على مصالح الاقتصاديه
اكثر من وجودها العسكريه السياسي الوجود
العسكري في طريقه الى زوال بعد ان بات
محصور لدلاله اشهر تريد النجوم اسرع من
ذلك ونزود الدبلوماسي انتهى اليوم بعد
وصول السفير الى فرنسا وقطع العلاقه بشكل
نهائي مع الحكام الجدد النيجر وبالتالي
الدرس الان هي في بحث عن اقل الخسائر وهو
ان تبقى لها وجود اقتصادي ووجود رمزي في
منطقه النيجر يحفظ لها ما وجهها واعتقد
انها بحاجه الى اصدقاء يلعبون لها الدور
هي لم تعد لديها قدره على اقناع بذلك شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد احمد ولد بابا الباحث
والمحلل السياسي المختص في الشان الافريقي
ضيفنا من نواكشوط
[موسيقى]
من جانبها رحبت الخارجيه الامريكيه بقبول
اذربيجان بفتره او بفكره نشر مراقبين
دوليين بشان عمليات النزوح من كاراباخ في
الاثناء يتواصل حراق دبلوماسي غربي بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا حيث التقى الرئيس
الاذربيجاني الهام علياف في العاصمه باكو
رئيسه الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
سمانتا باور ويضم الوفد الامريكي مساعده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون الاوروبيه
والاسيه يوريكيمي وقد قدم الوفد قدم الوفد
من يريفان حيث بحث الوضع في كاراباخ مع
رئيس الوزراء الارميني
في الاثناء صرح مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الارميني انا رئيس الوزراء نيكول باشنيان
والرئيسه الفرنسي ايمانيويل ماكرون بحثا
في اتصال هاتفيا بينهما الاوضاع في اقليم
كاراباخ وازمه نزوح الارمن من الاقليم
من جهتها اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
انا لينا باير بوك زياده بلادها لقيمه
المساعدات الانسانيه للجنه الصليب الاحمر
الدوليه من 2 الى 5 ملايين دولار وذلك
لدعم النازحين من كاراباخ وطالبت باير
بوكا اذربيجان بالسماح بدخول المراقبين
الدوليين الى الاقليم
وفي مقابل الحراك الغربي ذكرت الخارجيه
الروسيه ان الوزير سيرجي لافروف بحث
هاتفيا مع وزير خارجيه اذربيجان الوضع في
كراباخ وان الوزيرين يبحثان قضايا
المساعدات الانسانيه وامن الارمن في كرباخ
اضافه الى سبل تنفيذ الاتفاقيات بشان
معاهده السلام بين باكو وريفان وترسيم
الحدود
وقد دعا وزير الخارجيه الروسي سرجينا
القياده في ارمينيا الى التذكر مصير الدول
التي اعتمدت على الولايات المتحده واصبحت
في وضع لا تحسد عليه على حد تعبيره وقال
لافروف في مقابله مع وكاله تاس الروسيه
انه من المستحيل ان تفقد موسكو مصالحها في
جنوب القوقاز
من الناحيه التاريخيه والجيوسيه من
المستحيل ان تفقد روسيا مصالحها في جنوب
القوقاز او يتم تجاهلها بعض السياسيين في
ياريفان ومنهم رئيس الوزراء نيكولا يريدون
ان تفقد ارمينيا علاقاتها مع روسيا وتجد
اصدقاء جدد نقول اذا اعتمدوا على الولايات
المتحده فربما يكون من الجيد لهم ان
ينظروا الى التاريخ الحديث وكيف تعاملت
الولايات المتحده مع من احتوتهم تحت
جناحيها ساعيه وراء مصالحها الجيوسياسيه
ينضم الينا من القاهره
المحلل السياسي والاستراتيجي سيد كالفن
يقول
من المستحيل ان تفقد موسكو مصالحها في
جنوب القوقاز هل فعلا من المستحيل ان يحدث
ذلك باعتقادك
مرحبا نعم يسعدني ان اكون معكم انا كنت مع
وفدا من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفد
خاص الى منطقه كرباخ وباكو الشهر الماضي
وشاهدت العديد من هذه المسائل
كشهد عيان في الميدان بالنسبه الى دوري
روسيا من بين الامور التي كانت واضحه هي
ان روسيا ولانها طبعا تركز على اوكرانيا
لم تؤدي الدوره الذي كان من يتعير عليها
ان تؤديه بالنسبه الى السلام
وبالنسبه الى الارمن
والارمينيين والاثر به شاينين للتفاوض
وبالتالي الان هناك مضيق قدما في هذه
الثوره التي نشهدها او هذه التطورات التي
نشهدها في الاسابيع الماضيه وهي تثبت ان
روسيا لم تؤدي الدور
المرجو منها وبالتالي هذا هو موضوع روسيا
في منطقه القوقا وبالتالي بناء على ذلك
ماذا وراء دعوه الدعوه الان لدخول مراقبين
دوليين الى الاقليم
اعتقد ان هذه الدعوات تمثل افضل نتيجه
يمكننا ان نتوقعها دعونا نتذكر انه قبل
العمليات العسكريه التي بدات في الاسابيع
الماضيه الهدف كان الحل السلمي للنزاع
والمساله الوحيده التي كانت تعرقل ذلك
كانت الضمانات من قبل الحكومه في اذربيجان
حول وضع الارمن المقيمين في كارباخ الان
بالتصعيد العسكري في المنطقه هناك الالاف
من الارمن الذين يغادرون الاقليم باتجاه
ارمينيا واصبحت هذه المساله اقل اهميه
الان المساله الاساسيه المرتبطه بحل
النزاع وخصوصا بالنسبه الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي التاكد ان اولئك
الذين بقوا في منطقه كراباخ لديهم حقوق
محميه لانه هو بكل تاكيد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والاسره الدوليه ترى ان هذا
الاقليم هو جزء من اذربيجان وبالتالي
المراقبون الدوليون هم الحل بنظر الولايات
المتحده والاسره الدوليه لان من شانهم ان
يضمنوا سلامه الناس في تلك المنطقه وهذا
التطور ايجابي ضمان سلامه الناس من جهه
ولكن ايضا ربما الحلول
الموجوده في تلك المنطقه وتقويد النفوذ
الروسي هناك بشكل نهائي اليس كذلك
يمكن ان يكون الوضع كذلك ولكن بناء على ما
شاهدته في الميدان ولان روسيا تركز على
احتلال اوكرانيا لم تظهر قوتها في المنطقه
تلك واعتقد انه اذا ما عدنا الى تصريحاتي
وزير الخارجيه
المساله خطره بالنسبه الى روسيا لانها لا
تود ان تفقد التاثير والنفوذ في جنوب
القوقاز ولكن في الحقيقه ليس لدى روسيا
نفس النفود الذي كان لديها
الارمينيون الان يطرحون الاسئله من هو
الحليف روسيا او لربما يجب
نسجات افضل مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
طبعا تركيا لديها علاقات مقربه مع ازار
باجان وبالتالي الوضع على ما هو عليه
روسيا تخسر النفوذ والسؤال بالنسبه الى
روسيا ما الذي سوف تقوم به لحل هذه
المشكله
موضوع عن مراقبين الدوليين سيد كالفن نحن
شاهدنا خلال ايام قليله خروج نحو خمسين
الف ارمني من ارمني كاراباخ من اصل 120
الفا اصلا تعهدوا جميعا بحسب سلطات
الاقليم بانهم يريدون ان لا يكونوا
مواطنين في اذربيجان ويريدون الذهاب الى
ارمينيا وبالتالي ان كان ان كانت وتيره
النزوح بهذه السرعه
يعني كيف سيتم العمل على تجميع قوات
مراقبين دوليين
ونشرهم في الاقليم ان كانت وتيره النزوح
بهذه السرعه كما ذكرت
نعم بالفعل انت على حق عندما كنت في
اقليمي كارابا كنت في ما يسمى منطقه
المحرره هذا وفقا لمصطلحي اذربيجان وعندما
تحدثت مع الناس في المنطقه اوضحوا انهم
بحاجه الى ثقه بالحكومه في اذربيجان بانها
سوف تحترم حقوق هؤلاء وعندما التقيت
المسؤولين في اذربيجانبين بين الامور التي
اصر عليها هي انهم سوف يحمون هذه الحقوق
وكل ما يحصل في الاقليم هو تحت سيطره
اذربيجان لان الاقليم هو جزء من اراضي
اذربيجان وبالتالي المراقبون الدوليون اذا
ما وصلوا هي خطوه ايجابيه ولكن لا اعتقد
ان ازا البادجان سوف تترك المراقبين
يعملون هم بل ان الحكومه هي التي سوف تكون
مسيطره في ذاك المكان شكرا المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من القاهره
لم يعد حمل الاعلام الامريكيه والاوروبيه
في شوارع يريفان مشهدا مستغربا
يطالب انصار هذا التيار المعارض بدور غربي
يعود نظيره الروسي
وباستقاله رئيس الوزراء لكل فاشينيان الذي
يتهمونه بالتواطئ مع موسكو في ازمه
كاراباخ
ندعو لخروج ارمينيا من كل المنظمات
الاقليميه التابعه لروسيا وتعزيز علاقاتنا
مع واشنطن والدول الاوروبيه كل الاتفاقيات
بشان كهربا باطله لا يخلو محيط السفاره
الروسيه في ريفان من محتجين على سياسات
موسكو في ملف كراباخ وهي التي تؤكد توازن
موقفها وتتهم في المقابل رئيس الوزراء
الارميني ذا الميول الغربيه بمحاوله تعليق
فشله في اداره الملف على روسيا تنقسم
المواقف هنا بشان الدوري الروسي في ملف
كاراباخ التعقيدات الراهنه توحي بظهور
مزيد من الطيارات ذات الميول الغربيه وهو
ما تحصله روسيا في اطار مساع امريكيه
لتحجيم دورها في الفضاء الاوراسي كما سبق
وحدث في بلدان سوريا سابقه
يعج هذا المقهى الروسي وسط يريفان
بالزبائن منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
ينهمك الذي قرر الهجره قبل عام من روسيا
الى ارمينيا في عمله الى جانب زملائه
الروسي ايضا يقول ان القربى الجغرافيه
والروابط الثقافيه والاقتصاديه وشعبيه
اللغه الروسيه عوامل مشجعه على العيش هنا
استغرقت مساله التاقلم هنا في ارمينيا
شهرين فقط علاقه الارمينيين بالروس جيده
جدا رغم الاحداث الاخيره في شوارع يريفان
كثيرا ما يبرز الحضور الروسي في هذا البلد
السوفيتي السابق نحو 300 الف روسي يقيمون
اليوم في ارمينيا تشغل الاموال الروسيه
نحو ثلث مجموع الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وتعد
موسكو اكبر شريك تجاري لريفان باكثر من
خمسه مليارات دولار سنويا
السؤال الاهم الى اي مدى نحن بحاجه الى
التخلي عن التعاون مع روسيا اذا كان ذلك
ضروريا فان ارمينيا تحتاج الى عشر سنوات
على الاقل ثم تم معطيات تمثل وفق مراقبين
سيمامه امان لمستقبل العلاقات بين يريفان
وموسكو القاعده العسكريه الروسيه في جمري
واتفاقيات التكامل والدفاع المشترك فضلا
عن قوات حرس الحدود الروسيه المنتشره على
طول حدود ارمينيا مع جيرانها لكن مستقبل
تلك العلاقات في رايي كثيرين مفتوح على كل
الاحتمالات في ضوء واقع جيوسياسي اقليمي
يحفل بالمتغيرات
امين الجزيره هيريفان
[موسيقى]
هي تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
تهمت الخارجيه الروسيه من سمتهم اختصاصيين
امريكيين وبريطانيين بتنسيق مع اوكرانيا
في هجومها على مقر الاسطول الروسي في
القرم يوم الجمعه الماضي وعلى صعيد
العمليات العسكريه قال الجيش الاوكراني
انه يواصل تقدمه ويتصدى لمحاولات هجوميه
روسيه على محاور عده في حين هاجمت القوات
الروسيه مستودعه ذخيره تابعا للقوات
الاوكرانيه في خرسون جنوبيه البلاد ومركز
تحكم عسكري في مقاطعه دونيتسك شرق
اوكرانيا
تلتهب المحاور عشرات الاشتباكات القتاليه
خلال ساعات تلك ساعات الافضل بحسب
الاوكرانيين الى تحقيقهم عمليه تقدم جديده
في اقليم دومباس بشرقي البلاد ذكر مثلا
شان محوري ضخمه
يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني فضلا عن ذلك تصديه
لمحاوله هجوميه روسيه على
محورينيكا كما يواصل عمليه التمشيط حول
بلده كليشيفكا التي اعاد السيطره عليها
قبل اسبوع من زاويه النظر الاوكرانيه
ستتراء لك انجازات الهجوم المضاد الذي قيل
بشانه الكثير
حتى على مستوى الدفاع ستتبدى انجازات من
نوع اخر
لعل من ذلك حديث الجيش الاوكراني عن تصديه
لعشرات الغارات الجويه والهجمات
بالمقذوفات الصاروخيه التي تستهدف في
الغالب موانئ اوديسا وصوامع تخزين الحبوب
لكن للروس ايضا زاويه ينظرون من خلالها
لمجريات الميدان
ما يسمونها عملياتهم العسكريه في اوكرانيا
لا يعوقها كما يقولون كل المدد العسكري
الذي يتلقاه الطرف الاخر من الغرب
في احدث هجماته استهدف الجيش الروسي مركز
تحكم عسكري في
شرق اوكرانيا
اما هناك جنوبا فهدف هذه المره مستودع
ذخيره تابع للقوات الاوكرانيه في بلده
كيسيليفكا بمقاطعه خرسون غير ان تاثيرات
استمرار الهجمه الاوكرانيه لاسيما
بالطائرات المسيره امر يصعب على موسكو
مداراته هذا جسر القرم الاستراتيجي الذي
تعرض لهجمات اوكرانيه متكرره خلال الشهور
الماضيه
ربما كانت تجدد الهجمات هو ما حمل روسيا
مجددا على تعليق حركه المرور على الجسر
قبل ان تستانفها في وقت لاحق الهجوم
الاخير على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
في سباستوبل هو واحد من الهجمات التي
تعدوها كييف نوعيه يخرج قائد الاسطول
فيكتور الذي قال الاوكرانيون انه قتل في
الهجوم ليؤكد ان مهام اسطوله تنفذ بنجاح
كما حددتها القياده
اللافت للنظر اكثر ان تخرج موسكو الان
لتوجه اصابع الاتهام الى كل من لندن
وواشنطان
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخارفا قالت ان كيا هاجمت الجمعه الماضيه
مقر الاسطول الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
بالتنسيق مع من سمته باختصاصيين امريكيين
وبريطانيين
اتهام اخر باثر رجعي تقول موسكو ان واشنطن
ضالعتان بشكل او باخر في تفجير انابيب
ستريم قبل نحو عام
كما نعلم يعتبر من اهم المنشات المزوده
للطاقه وكان يمد العديد من الدول
الاوروبيه بالغاز
[موسيقى]
الى السودان ففي ضم المعارك المستمره في
انحاء البلاد قالت وزاره الصحه السودانيه
ان الفحص المعملي اكد حدوث وفيات واصابات
بالكوليرا في ولايه الجضارف شرقيه السودان
وذلك بعد التعامل مع حالات اشتباه بلغت
265 اصابه وثماني عشره وفاه
وفي ولايه القضارف ايضا وصفت اداره مستشفى
الاطفال بالولايه الوضع بالكارسي وقالت ان
مئات الاطفال توفوا بسبب سوء التغذيه
وامراض مختلفه اخرى بسبب ظروف الحرب
احتواء اثار الحرب في السودان ما زال مجرد
عنوان عام
فالتدهور تجاوز الاوضاع الامنيه لفئات
السودانيين كافه
الاطفال بشكل خاص هي الفئه الاكثر هشاشه
فالحرب شردت كثيرين منهم وجعلتهم عرضه
للجوع والامراض والنزوح الى مختلف مدن
السودان هنا في مركز للرعايه الصحيه
بمدينه القضارف
تبحث حليمه عن علاج لطفلتها بعد ان بدا
وزنها في التناقص يوما بعد يوم وعكب اجراء
الفحوصات الاوليه تاكد لها ان ابنتها
تعاني سوءا في التغذيه
[موسيقى]
ظروف ماما ساعدني عشان
بلغ عدد مراجعي هذا المركز اكثر من الف
طفل شهريا معظمهم يعانون سوءا في التغذيه
في مستشفى القضارف للاطفال
تكدس الاطفال المرضى ومن اسعفه الحظ في
الوصول الى طبيب وجد ان الطبيب يحتاج الى
من يزعفه
بالامكانيات الطبيه
[موسيقى]
قلنا بنلاقي هنا
واحد
وفقا لمستشفى الاطفال توفي اكثر من 130
طفلا بسبب امراض مختلفه ابرزها سوء
التغذيه والاسهال ونقص الادويه صراحه
الوضع في المستشفى
الوضع الصح
في كل مقومات العمليات الطبيه نقص في
الادويه في الكوادر
ومعينات العمل
الحرب في السودان
حصدت ارواح مئات الاطفال
والملايين منهم في امس الحاجه الى
المساعدات والدعم النفسي منذ اندلاع الحرب
يعيش هؤلاء الاطفال مع ذويهم في مراكز
ايواء تنعدم فيها مقومات الحياه الكريمه
الفقر كان سابقا فجاتي الحرب لتجعله سابقا
ولاحقا وحادا حتى الموت ومن لم يمت فروحه
تعاني مشاهده افعال القتل وشتى انواع
العنف الطاهره المرضي الجزيره القضارف
اصيب فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال قمعها مظاهره قرب الشريط
الحدودي شرق خان يونس جنوبيه قطاع غزه
واطلق جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الرصاصه
الحي وقنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع لتفريق
المتظاهرين بينما اشعل الشبان اطارات
مطاطيه قرب السياج الامني تمديدا بتصاعد
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله وللمطالبه برفع الحصار
الاسرائيلي المفروض على القطاع منذ سته
عشر عاما
دعا المنسق الاممي الخاص لعمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط توروينزلاند اسرائيل الى وقف
جميع انشطتها الاستيطانيه وتفكيك البؤر
الاستيطانيه على الفور وجدد وينزلند خلال
كلمه امام جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي
التاكيد على ان المستوطنات تشكل انتهاكا
صارخا للقانون الدولي
المستوطنات تزيد من ترسيخ الاحتلال وتؤجج
العنف وتعوق وصول الفلسطينيين الى اراضيهم
ومواردهم وتؤدي بشكل منهجي الى تاكل
قابليه الدوله الفلسطينيه للحياه كجزء من
حل الدولتين اجدد التاكيد بان المستوطنات
ليس لها اي شرعيه قانونيه وتشكل انتهاكا
صارخا للقانون الدولي وقرارات الامم
المتحده وادعو حكومه اسرائيل الى وقف
الانشطه الاستيطانيه وتفكيك البؤر
الاستيطانيه على الفور بما يتماشى مع
التزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي
من جانبها عربه المندوبه الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن الدولي ليندا توماس
مستويات العنف في اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه
بما في ذلك العنف في غزه الذي ادى الى
اغلاق مؤقت لمعبر بيت حانون وحفت جرين
فيلد اسرائيل على الامتناع عن الانشطه
الاستيطانيه
تشعر الولايات المتحده بقلق عميق ايذاء
مستويات العنف في اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه
وغزه بما في ذلك العنف في غزه الذي ادى
الى الاغلاق المؤقت لمعبر ايريس وتعارض
الولايات المتحده بشده تطوير المستوطنات
وتحث اسرائيل على الامتناع عن هذا النشاط
ناخذ هذه القضيه على محمل الجد لانها تقوض
امكانيه قيام دوله فلسطينيه متصله جغرافيا
في المستقبل ونطرحها على اعلى المستويات
على اساس ثابت
واتهم المندوب الروسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي
غسيليا واشنطن بالتحايل على منطق مبادره
السلام العربيه من خلال الترويج للتطبيع
العربي الاسرائيلي وقال ان العالم يشهد
تفكيكا فعليا للاطار القانوني الدولي
المقبول عالميا للتسويه السلميه بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
نشعر بالقلق ايزاء استمرار تدهور الوضع في
الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني بينما لا
يزال هناك فراغ في المسار التفاوضي وغياب
لاي افق لعمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط
وفي حين نشهد تفكيكا فعليا للاطار
القانوني الدولي المقبول عالميا للتسويه
السلميه تواصل الولايات المتحده ترويج
للتطبيع العربي الاسرائيلي الذي يتحايل
على منطق مبادره السلام العربي
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ووزير الامن الداخلي اليخاندرو مايوركاس
قبول اسرائيل في برنامج الاعفاء من
التاشيره وقال في بيان ان انضمام اسرائيل
الى البرنامج والمتطلبات الصارمه التي
ينطوي عليها سيجعل بلديهما اكثر امنا
وسيتيح القرار للاسرائيليين دخول الولايات
المتحده بدون تاشيره اعتبارا من الثلاثين
من نوفمبر تشرين الثاني المقبل
قالت اداره امني محافظه ابيان جنوبيه
اليمن ان خمسه جنود قتلوا واصيب ثلاثه في
اشتباكات مع مسلحين وصفتهم بالارهابيين
واوضحت الاداره في بيان ان الاشتباكات
اندلعت امس الثلاثاء خلال حمله امنيه
لتطهير منطقه وادي الرفض اسفلت عن السيطره
على مواقع كثيره تابعه لمن وصفتهم
بالعناصر الارهابيه والحقت بهم خسائر
كبيره في حين توعد مدير امن ابيا ببسط
سيطره قوات الامن على كامل اوديه عمران
والسلاسل الجبليه التابعه لها وتشن قوات
الامن وقوات الامن الحكوميه في ابين عمليه
عسكريه منذ اشهر على مواقع مسلحين متهمين
بالانتماء لتنظيم القاعده اسفلت عن مقتل
واصابه العشرات من الطرفين
قالت مساعده مدير مكتب المساعدات
الانسانيه التابعه للوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه الدوليه ساره تشارلز ان واشنطن
خصصت 12 مليون دولار لمساعده ليبيا على
تجاوز كارثه الفيضانات
فيما يخص ليبيا افرجت الامم المتحده عن
عشره ملايين دولار على الفور لمواجهه اثار
الفيضانات وسمح هذا لعدد من شركاء المنظمه
الدوليه بالاستجابه الفوريه للفيضانات دون
انتظار تمويل من مانحين اخرين كما خصصت
الولايات المتحده 12 مليون دولار لمساعده
ليبيا
في المغرب افادت مصادر محليه في بلديه
مراكش للجزيره ان عدد المنازل المتضرره من
زلزال الحوز بلغ اكثر من ثمانيه الاف منزل
وفق ما تم احصائه حتى امس الثلاثاء واوضحت
المصادر انه بعد معاينه الفرق التقنيه
المتخصصه لوضعيه المنازل صدرت قراراته هدم
كلي لقرابه 300 منزل وهدم جزئي لنفس العدد
وتهدف عمليه الاحصاء الى تعويض المتضررين
ضمن برنامج الحكومه لاعاده تاهيل المناطق
المتضرره
قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان
واشنطن تمكنت من تامين عوده الجندي ترافيس
كينج الذي كان محتجزا في كوريا الشماليه
وقدم سالفا لكل من السويد على دورها
الدبلوماسي والصين لمساعدتها في عبور
الجندي كينج وقال مسؤولون بالاداره
الامريكيه ان الصين لعبت دورا وصفه
بالبناء في نقل الجندي عبر الاراضي
الصينيه مشيرا الى ان واشنطن تبقى منفتحه
على السبل الدبلوماسيه مع كوريا الشماليه
وفي وقت سابق افادت وكاله انباء كوريا
الشماليه بان السلطات قررت طرد الجندي
الامريكي بعد انتهاء التحقيق معه وبعد
توغله في يوليو حزيره او تموز الماضي عبر
الحدود الى كوريا الشماليه اضافت ان
الجندي اعترف بدخول الاراضي الكوريه
الشماليه بشكل غير قانوني بسبب استيائه
على حد قولها من المعامله غير الانسانيه
داخل الجيش الامريكي
جوله الحصاد متواصله معكم على راس الساحه
عدد ضحايا حريق الحمدانيه بالعراق يقترب
من المئه تشييع الضحايا وايقاف عدد من
المتهمين وسلطات تعزو الكارثه لاستخدام
العاب ناريه خلال حفل الزفاف والناطق باسم
الحكومه يقر في حديث للجزيره بوجود تقصير
في متابعه معايير السلام
سفير فرنسا في النيجر يعود الى باريس بعد
شهر من مطالبه المجلس العسكري له
بالمغادره ومكروه يؤكد مواصله الجهود
لاستعاده النظام الدستوري في ميامي وفي
جولاتها الافريقيه وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ينتقد الانقلابات ويقول ان القاره تحتاج
الى مؤسسات فعاله يقودها مدنيون
في خضم حراك غربي بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
ترحيب امريكي بقبول اذربيجان بفكره نشر
مراقبين دوليين بشان عمليات النزوح من
كاراباغ وموسكو تدعو قاده ارمينيا لتذكر
مسمته مصير الدول الحديثه للولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]
اذا فاجعه انسانيه جديده في العراق
ضحاياها يناهزون المئتين بين قتيلا ومصاب
اسره حريق اندلع بقاعه زفاف في منطقه
الحمدانيه بمحافظه نينوى وشماليه البلاد
وقال الناطق باسم وزاره الصحه العراقيه ان
عدد القتل بلغ اربعه وتسعين وتجاوز عدد
المصابين مئه شخص اضاف في تصريح للجزيره
ان هذه الحصيله ليست نهائيه بسبب وجود
العديد من الحالات التي وصفها بالحرجه في
مستشفيات الموصل
هدوء هذه الخيمه لا يعكس ما يعتمل في صدور
الجالسين فيها فقد سامان امه في الحريق
وفقد معها ولديه وزوجته في دقائق معدودات
[موسيقى]
داخل البيت لم تتمالك هؤلاء النسوه انفسهم
ففي هذه الدوابيت فضلا عن جثامين الاحبه
ما يذكر بالفاجعه كتب لبعضهن النجاه من
حريق الحمدانيه باعجوبه لكن الاسى على من
رحلوا اقوى واشد مجرد
شويه نار جميل القاعه
شغله دقائق كلها احترقتها
من تقدر لا تطب لا تطلع ما تقدر قرب البيت
من قاعه الاعراس المحترقه ينكؤ جراح
العائله وينظرها ان النسيان سيكون صعبا
وربما بقدر صعوبه تلك الليله العصيبه حدث
كل شيء بسرعه شراره فنار فحريق التهم كل
شيء تاركا المئات بين قتيل وجريح ومصاب
بصدمه يصعب ان تشفى
تشير الروايه الرسميه الى ان السبب ثلاثي
الاضلاع مواد بناء رديئه قابله للاشتعال
واحتفال بالعاب ناريه وغياب مخارج الطوارئ
وصفه متكامله للكارثه جميع التعزيز
ات ومن الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه
والصحيه وحاليا الوضع مسيطر عليه في داخل
المستشفى بالكامل شكلنا لجنه تحقيقيه
لتحديد ملابسات الحادث والمقصرين وراح
ينالون جزاهم العادل
لجنه مركزيه مشتركه من قبل
الاستخبارات والدفاع المدني والشرطه
على اجواء البلده غمامه حزن ممزوج بالغضب
فما حدث يقول سكانها كان بالامكان تفاديه
وغياب القانون والمساءله ستبقى هذه القبور
شهده على يوم ماساوي في ذاكره الحمدانيه
يوم لم ترى البلده مثيرا له في تاريخها
ويامنوه سكانها الا تذهب ارواح الضحايا
سدن وان تستخلص عبر الكارثه تفاديا
لتكرارها
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال وزير الداخليه
العراقيه عبد الامير الشمري ان التحقيقات
في حريق الحمدانيه مستمره وسيتم الاعلان
عن نتائجها خلال الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
المقبله اضاف ان جميع المتهمين باتوا في
قبضه العداله
كل المتهمين في القضيه في قبضه العداله
حاليا الشخص اللي صاحب القاعه
ايضا الاشخاص اللي كانوا يديرون موضوع
الالعاب الناريه داخل القاعده
عليهم في
القاعده تم توقيفه
ومستمرين بالتحقيق وسيتم انجاز تحقيق
واعلان خلال 2070 ساعه القادمه
اضاف وزير الداخليات العراقي في حديثه
للجزيره ان 14 شخصا اعتقلوا على خلفيه
الحريق وان من بين الاجراءات التي ستتخذ
اغلاق الاماكن العامه التي استخدمت المواد
سريعه الاشتعال في بناءها
ومنغلق هذه الاماكن العامه اللي مبنيه
بمواد بناء سريعه
الدفاع المدني مع الاجزاء الامنيه الاخرى
وكذلك
من قبل الساده المحافظين باعتبارهم رؤسائم
للجانب الفرعيه للدفاع المدني في
المحافظاتهم
لهذه المحلات
وقال الناطق باسم الحكومه العراقيه باسم
العوادي ان تقصيرا قد حدث بالفعل في ملف
مراقبه شروط المطلوبه لسلامه المباني
والمؤسسات اضاف العواد في حديث للجزيره ان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي امر باعاده النظر في
هذا الملف
هناك تقصير يقع على عاتق بعض المؤسسات في
المتابعه لكن هذا التقصير هو كما تعرفون
يعني يتحرك من الدائره الابيض بالنهايه
تحال القضيه الى مجموعه مراقبين في
البلديات وهؤلاء المراقبين طبعا يتعاطون
مع هذه المخازن
وفق صغرها صغر حجمها او كبرها قلت هذا
الحاله الشعبيه او الحاله الروحيه احيانا
كثيره هي تنعكس على هذا الاداء المهم كان
واحد من اهم توجيهات لسيد رئيس الوزراء
اليوم هو الرجوع مره اخرى الى هذا الملف
تجديد اجراءات السلامه والتحرك على كل
المباني
تنضم الينا من الحمدانيه في محافظه نينوى
مراسله الجزيره ستير حكيم ستير كيف يتطور
الموقف بعد تشييع القتلى وماذا عن
التطورات المتعلقه بصحه الجرحى ومنهم في
المستشفيات
يمكن القول باختصار ان الصفه الابرز الان
داخل قضاء الحمدانيه هي حزن وايضا الصدمه
من هول هذه الفاجعه التي حدثت ليله امس
لكن مع ساعات الليل يبدو ان هذا الموقع
الذي كان قد شهد نشوبا للحريق بدا بالهدوء
انتقل المدنيين وتوجهوا عادوا الى منازلهم
لكن بعد مرور الان اكثر من 24 ساعه الان
اعين
اسر وعوائل الضحايا تتوجه الى التحقيقات
ونتائجها لاسيما وان الحكومه والسلطات
وعدت باجراء تحقيقات ومحاسبه المتورطين
والذين يقفون وراء هذه الحادثه التي اسفلت
عن وقوع عدد عشرات من الجرحى والقتله هذه
الاعداد مرجحه طبعا للزياده بحسب المصادر
الطبيه لاسيما وان الحديث يدور عن ان عدد
من هذه الحالات التي وصلت الى المستشفيات
هي حالات حرجه تعرضت لحروق من الدرجه
الثانيه والثالثه الان كما ذكرنا بعد
تشييع ودفن الضحايا الان هم ينتظرون نتائج
التحقيقات
ويطالبون السلطات والحكومه
بمعاقبه المتورطين وليس فقط مالك هذه
القاعه ويقولون بان اعتقال هؤلاء ليس حلا
للمشكله التي تبدو اكبر من موقع او قاعه
داخل هذه المدينه وايضا في مدن عراقيه
كثيره نعرف ان هذه الابنيه هذا النوع من
الابنيه التي تشيد بمواد اسفنجيه او مواد
سريعه
الاشتعال هي منتشره بشكل واسع
يتم استخدام صفائح من الالمنيوم بداخلها
مواد من مواد هي سريعه الاشتعال وقابله
للاشتعال اضافه الى ذلك معظم هذه القاعات
غير ملتزمه ملتزمه بشروط السلامه والامان
لذلك هم يطالبون بفرض مزيد من الرقابه من
السلطات والبلديات داخل المحافظات والمدن
العراقيه شكرا جزيلا لك استير حكيم حدثنا
من امام قاعه الهيثم في حيث وقع هذا
الحادث في الحمدانيه في محافظه نينوى
وشكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في النيجر اذ اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه عوده سفير باريس في
نيامه تزامن ذلك مع تجديد الرئيس الفرنسي
التزامه بمواصله العمل من اجل عوده النظام
الدستوري الى النيجر وفي السياق نفسه
يتحدث وزير الدفاع الامريكي بان القاره
الافريقيه كلها بحاجه الى مؤسسات يقودها
مدنيون
لم يعد السفير الفرنسي هنا يترك سلوفان
مقر عمله في النيجر بعد شهر من مطالبه
المجلس العسكري له بالمغادره يصل باريس
بعد ان كانت رفضت ما وصفته بالرضوخ لمطالب
المجلس العسكري في النيجر بحلول نهايه
العام ستنهي فرنسا وجودا عسكريا في النيجر
استمر عقودا قبل وبعد الاستقلال في النيجر
تمركزت لاعوام قوه فرنسيه من اكثر من الف
جندي في قاعده جويه متقدمه في العاصمه
نيامي لكن النيجر تستضيف قوه اجنبيه
متنوعه تتمركز قوات امريكيه في قاعدتين
جويتين تضمان 1200 جندي لالمانيا هناك
110 جنود في عاصمه النيجر بالاضافه الى
250 جنديا ايطاليا الى جانب اقل من 100
جندي تابعين للاتحاد الاوروبي
لا مشكله مع هذه القوات يقول النا باسم
المجلس العسكري في البلاد ولن يطلب منها
الانسحاب الاهم بالنسبه للمجلس العسكري
انه لا يريد قوات بديله للجنود الفرنسيين
المغادرين وسط كل هذه القرارات المهمه في
تاريخ النيجر يجدد ماكرون دعمه عوده
النظام الدستوري في النيجر وفي السياق
نفسه يتحدث وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي يرى
ان القاره الافريقيه كلها بحاجه الى
مؤسسات يقودها مدنيون
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بدعم السياسات
الحكوميه التي تعمل على تعزيز السلام
والامن والحكم الديمقراطي ففي جميع انحاء
القاره راينا مستبدين يقوضون الانتخابات
الحره والنزيهه ويمنعون الانتقال السلميه
للسلطه لكن كلام الوزير الامريكي لم يقلق
المسؤولين العسكريين في النيجر تبقي
واشنطن نفسها بمنع عن توتر حكام النيجر
الجدد مع فرنسا اذ يبدو ان الازمه بالفعل
محصوره بين النيامي بحلتها الجديده وباريس
بتاريخها الاستعماري هكذا يبدا العد
التنازلي للوجود الفرنسي في النيجر بعد
عقود من الاستعمار وما لحقه من تعاون
سياسيا وعسكري وصل حد التحالفات
الاستراتيجيه
ينضم الينا من نيام عبد الرحمن حميد عيسى
مستشار رئيس البرلمان في النيجر مرحبا بك
سيد عبد الرحمن حميد عيسى كيف تلقيتم
الرساله الفرنسيه من وراء سحب السفير بعد
الاسابيع من الامتناع عن ذلك رغم مطالبه
السلطات السلطات في النيجر بسحب السفير
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله ولن نحييكم
واحيي مشاهدينا الكرام واحيي شعبنا العظيم
الشعب النيجري وابارك له هذا الانتصار
الكبير
واقول ان
الانتصار
في المعارك ليس هو النجاح كما يقال النجاح
التام هو ان تكسر مقاومه العدو دون قتال
فلا شك ان الشعب النيجر انتصر ولا شك ان
فرنسا
رغم سياساتها الاستفزازيه التي كانت تستفز
بها الشعب النيجر في
الاسابيع الماضيه منذ الانقلاب خلال ما
يقارب شهرين كلها اصبحت
كالرماد
وادركت فرنسا ان الشعب النيجري اصبح اكثر
وعيا من اي وقت مضى وان الجيل الجديد لا
يقبل الاملاءات التي تاتي من قبل
ماكرون وتاتي من قبل
لكن تقول انها اصبحت كرامات سيد عبد
الرحمن ولكن الرئيس الفرنسي يجدد
التعهد في حديثه عن انه
ملتزم بدعم الرئيس محمد بازون وان الرئيس
محمد بازون بالنسبه لفرنسا هو الرئيس
الدستوري والشرعي الوحيد ولو سيتم استمرار
العمل مع ايكوس وباقي الدول الاوروبيه من
اجل اعادته
هذه هي سياسات ماكرون دائما اذا هزم
يستنجد ببازون وهذا ليس حديث عهد به
ماكرون فقد قال هذا الكلام مرارا وتكرارا
وقد قال
منذ ان تم الانقلاب على الرئيس المعزول
بازون انه لا يعترف باي حكومه الا بحكومه
بازون
فهنا نقول لماكرون ان اراده الشعب النيجري
هي التي تقرر كل شيء هي التي تقرر من
سيحكمها وهي التي تقرر من سعر اس الدوله
فهذه السياسات الاستفزازيه لا تاتي بنفع
وانما لكن سيد عبد الرحمن سيد عبد الرحمن
هناك احتمالات متعدده قد تنجم عن هذا
الكلام
والتعهد الذي يطلقه ماكرون الذي اطلقه في
هذه المقابله تلفزيونيه التي اعلن فيها عن
سحب السفير ان كان العمل مع ايكوس او
العمل مع الاتحاد الاوروبي او الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ما هي الاحتمالات التي
تتحسب لها السلطات في النيجر من جراء هذا
الكلام
[موسيقى]
خلال لقائه مع
القناه التي
اجرى فيها الحوار قبل يومين التي اعلن
فيها انسحابهم من النيجر سياسته واضحه وهي
السياسه
العراقيه يعني زرع فتنه بين الشعب النيجر
بين الاقليه التي ينتمي اليها بازون وهي
اقليه عربيه وبين
الاقليات الاخرى وهذا ان شاء الله لن يفلح
فيه بازون لان الشعب النيجر اصبح اكثر
تماسكا من اي وقت سيد عبد الرحمن ماذا
الان السؤال عن انعكاس ما يحصل على
المصالح الاقتصاديه الفرنسيه في داخل
النيجر ولا سيما انشطه تعدين اليورانيوم
التي تقوم بها فرنسا اي انعكاس سيكون لكل
ذلك على هذه الانشطه
اكيد سيكون هناك انعكاسات ونحن راينا
اليوم قرار المؤسسات المدنيه التي طالبت
المجلس العسكري ان ينهي
الاعمال شركه اورانو التي
تستخرج اليورانيوم في شمال النيجر وهذا
المطلب مطلب اساسي والمؤسسات المدنيه
تقدمت برساله واضحه اليوم للمجلس العسكري
على ان ينهي يعني اي
اتفاقيه تتعلق بهذه الشركه فهذا طبعا
سيؤثر كثيرا على فرنسا
نحن نعرف ان فرنسا ما تجنيه من اليورانيوم
في النيجر يعني لا يكاد يصدقه العقل حينما
تاخذ فرنسا
يورانيوم النيجر مقابل 2000 فرنك يعني ما
لا يتجاوز اربعه دولار وتبعه في السوق
بحدود 160 الف فرنك سيفا ما يقارب 300
دولار فهذا يعني اكيد سيكون له
[موسيقى]
اضرار كبيره على الاقتصاد عبد الرحمن هل
هناك بالفعل توجه لدى سلطات الانقلاب
بانهاء هذه الانشطه الفرنسيه وهل هناك
بدائل لدى سلطات الانقلاب ان جرى انهاءها
نعم بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد هناك يعني تحرك
شعبي اولا الشعب هو الذي سيلزم المجلس
العسكري ان يغير هذه الاتفاقيات وهناك
بدائل كثيره هناك الصين وهناك
تركيا وهناك
امريكا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وغيرها
من الدول الكثيره التي تريده ان تتعامل مع
النيجر معامله المثل بالمثل
سوف تكون معاملتها معامله مبنيه على مبالغ
واسس ومبنيه على المصلحه العامه لكلى
الطرفين ليس
هذه الدول ستضحي ربما
بحسن العلاقه مع فرنسا مقابل الدخول الى
هذا القطاع في النيجر بالشكل الذي يمكن ان
تدخل به
بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد نحن اليوم نعيش في
عالم مصالح يعني لا يخفى على احد ان
العالم اليوم عالم مصالح فاذا كانت هذه
الدول ترى مصالحها في النيجر فبكل تاكيد
ستضحي ستضحي من اجل هذه
التواصل من جانب سلطات الانقلاب مع كل هذه
الجهات من اجل تامين بدائل على وجود نشاط
الفرنسي في التعدين تعدين اليورانيوم
ليست هناك يعني تحركات
بخصوص الملف اليورانيوم الى حد الان ولكن
هناك لقاءات تمت مع وفود وفد من الصين كان
تم اللقاء مع به قبل فتره قليله وهناك
ايضا السفراء دول منها تركيا ومنها ايران
ومنها يعني
كندا
كلهم تم الاقاضعهم وانتقوا برئيس الوزراء
الجديده رئيس وزراء المجلس الانتقالي فهذه
كلها يعني ان شاء الله علامات
التعامل سوف يتم هذه الاطراف باذن الله
تعالى شكرا لك عبد الرحمن حميد عيسى
مستشار رئيس البرلمان في النيجر ضيفنا من
نيامه
معنى من باريس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ما وصلت اليه الامور مع النيجر
وردوخ فرنسا على ما يبدو في النهايه الى
المطلب مطلب سلطات الانقلاب بسحب السفير
نعم من الواضح نحن نتحدث عن فشل دبلوماسي
لباريس بعد الموقف المتشدد الذي استمر
لاسابيع حيث ان فرنسا قبلت سحب سفيرها
وايضا ان تسحب
الجنود الفرنسيين بحلول ديسمبر من البلاد
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن خساره دبلوماسيه
فرنسا سوف
تنظر في الوضع وتراجع الوضع لن تغير في
موقفها بالنسبه الى المجلس العسكري سوف
تبقى وفيه
للرئيس بازوم الذي هو محتجز من قبل التهمه
العسكريه ولكن الم يكن هناك من وسيله اخرى
للتعبير عن هكذا موقف هل كانت ادا ره هذه
الازمه
ناجحه باعتقادك من جانب فرنسا
كلا ان اداره الازمه لم تكن ناجحه بالنسبه
الى فرنسا وفي الواقع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ابلت بلاء افضل من فرنسا حيث
انها ابقت الباب مواربا مع
العسكريين وفتحت قنوات
وفي الوقت نفسه لم تقبل بالانقلاب ولكن
فرنسا بالفعل تشددت في موقفها ولكن نحن
نعرف ان شخصيه الرئيس ماكرون هي كذلك هو
متشدد في موقفه ونحن وصلنا الى تراجع
دبلوماسيا وحتى تراجع استراتيجي لفرنسا
القوات الفرنسيه ايضا يمكن ان تتجه باتجاه
تشاد اذا خسرت فرنسا بوركينا فاسو مالي
وحتى جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى لربما ليس للاسباب الصحيحه بل
للاسباب الخاطئه ويبدو ان مكروه مستمر على
هذا المساجد
فيما يتعلق بالنيجر لانه يتعهد بانه بان
بزوم هو الرئيس الدستوري الوحيد وبانه
سيتم العمل مع ايكواس ومع باقي الدول
الاوروبيه لاعادته هل هذا امر واقعي
باعتقادك في هذه المرحله
اعتقد ان الرئيس الفرنسي لا يمكنه ان يعود
خطوات الى الوراء هو يرى ان
الانقلابات في افريقيا هي كارثيه ونحن نرى
انه في مالي كان هناك انقلابا عسكريا وهو
ليس الاول ونرى الان ما هو الوضع في مالي
بالاضافه الى ثوره الطوارق والتي ادت الى
عشرات من القتلى في شمال البلاد وايضا نرى
الجهاديين من تنظيم الدوله ومن القاعده
والذين يكسبون ارادا متزايده وبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان الانقلابات العسكريه هي بالحل
الناجع للبلدان الافريقيه والرئيس ماكرون
لا يمكنه ان يدعم هكذا عمليات
ونرى النتيجه
لكن سيد الان الان على ضوء ما وصلت اليه
هذه الازمه كان معنا قبل قليل مستشار رئيس
البرلمان يتحدث عن المطالبه الشعبيه في
النيجر بانهاء الانشطه الفرنسيه في تعدين
اليورانيوم وربما هناك توجه في المرحله
المقبله لفعل ذلك ما خيارات فرنسا ان وصلت
الامور الى هنا
في البدايه وبالنسبه الى موضوع
اليورانيوم لم يعد الوضع كما كان منذ
عشرات السنوات بالنسبه الى فرنسا وهناك
استيراد
لليورانيوم اقل بكثير مما كانت عليه
المستويات في التسعينيات من القرن الماضي
وبالتالي النيجر لم يعد الشركه الرئيس
لفرنسا بالنسبه الى اليورانيوم والتبادلات
في هذا المجال بين البلدين هي منخفضه
للغايه اود ان اذكر ان القوات الفرنسيه
كانت متواجده في النيجر بناء على طلب
السلطات في النيجر في الحكومه التي انتخبت
الديمقراطيا في النيجر هي التي طلبت من
فرنسا ان تاتي الى البلاد وبالتالي سوف
تنسحب فرنسا من النيجر بعد انسحابها من بو
وسوف تضع اولويات اخرى نصبه اعينها في
منطقه اسيا لربما في سنغافوره حيث ان هناك
تعاون عسكريا مهما هناك اعتقد ان فرنسا
تنسحب تدريجيا من افريقيا غرب افريقيا ليس
بشكل كامل نحن نعرفه ان لفرنسا ثلاث قواعد
اساسيه في السنغال وفي كوت ديفوار صاحب
العاج شكرا لك
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
الى اخر التطورات باقليم كاراباخ حيث
يتواصل تدفق المركبات التي تقل الاف
اللاجئين من سكان الاقليم على طول الطريق
الوحيد خارج الاقليم باتجاه ارمينيا وقدرت
الحكومه الارمنيه اعدادا اللاجئين من سكان
الاقليم الذين نزحوا الى اراضيها باكثر من
خمسين الفا اثناء وبعد المواجهه العسكريه
الاخيره بين اذربيجان وارمن الاقليم ياتي
هذا في ظل مخاوف ارمل كاراباخ من التعرض
لما يصفونه بانتقام سلطات اذربيجان اذا
بقوا في الاقليم
من جانبها رحبت الخارجيه الامريكيه بقبول
اذربيجان بفكره نشر مراقبين دوليين بشان
عمليات النزوح من كاراباخ في هذه الاثناء
يتواصل وحراكم دبلوماسي غربي بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا حيث التقى الرئيس الاذربيجاني
الهام علياف في العاصمه باكو رئيسه
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه سمانثى
باور ويضم الوفد الامريكي مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون الاوروبيه
والاوراسيه
وقد قدم الوفد من يريفان قدم الوفد
مينيريفان حيث بحث الوضع في كاراباخ مع
رئيس الوزراء الارميني
في الاثناء صرح مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الارميني ان رئيس الوزراء لكل باشليان
والرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكرون بحفاف
اتصال هاتفيا بينهما الاوضاع في اقليم
كاراباخ وازمه نزوح الارمل من الاقليم
وفي مقابل الحراك الغربي ذكرت الخارجيه
الروسيه ان الوزير
بحث هاتفيا مع وزير خارجيه اذربيجان الوضع
في كاراباخ وان الوزيرين يبحثان قضايا
المساعدات الانسانيه وامن الارمل في كرباخ
اضافه الى سبل تنفيذ الاتفاقيات بشان
معاهده السلام بين باكويريفان وترسيم
الحدود
ودعا وزير الخارجيه الروسي سرغي لافروف
القياده في ارمينيا الى تذكر مصير الدول
التي اعتمدت على الولايات المتحده واصبحت
في وضع لا تحسد عليه على حد تعبيره وقال
لافروف في مقابله مع وكاله تاسس الروسيه
انه من المستحيل ان تفقد موسكو مصالحها في
جنوب القوقاز
وفي خضم توتر الذي تشهد على العلاقات بين
ارمينيا وروسيا على خلفيه ملف كاراباخ
وتبادل الاتهامات بين الجانبين تبقى موسكو
اكبر شريك تجاري
واستثمارياريفان بحجم يصل الى نحو خمسه
مليارات دولار سنويا لكن ذلك لم يمنع من
تردد دعوات للمطالبه بتقليص مستوى
العلاقات مع روسيا وهو ما يراه كثيرون
مهمه ليست باليسير
لم يعد حمل الاعلام الامريكيه والاوروفيه
في شوارع يريفان مشهدا مستغربا
يطالب انصار هذا التيار المعارض بدور غربي
يعود نظيره الروسي
وباستقاله رئيس الوزراء نيكولفاشينيان
الذي يتهمونه بالتواطئ مع موسكو في ازمه
كاراباخ
ندعو لخروج ارمينيا من كل المنظمات
الاقليميه التابعه لروسيا وتعزيز علاقاتنا
مع واشنطن والدول الاوروبيه كل الاتفاقيات
بشان كهربا باطله لا يخلو محيط السفاره
الروسيه في ريفان من محتجين على سياسات
موسكو في ملف كراباخ وهي التي تؤكد توازن
موقفها وتتهم في المقابل رئيس الوزراء
الارميني ذا الميول الغربيه بمحاوله تعليق
فشله في اداره الملف على روسيا تنقسم
المواقف هنا بشان الدوري الروسي في ملف
كراباخ التعقيدات الراهنه توحي بظهور
المزيد من الطيارات ذات الميول الغربيه
وهو ما تحصله روسيا في اطار مساع امريكيه
لتحجيم دورها في الفضاء الاوراسي كما سبق
وحدث في بلدان سوريا السابقه
يعج هذا المقهى الروسي وسط يريفان
بالزبائن منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
ينهمك الذي قرر الهجره قبل عام من روسيا
الى ارمينيا في عمله الى جانب زملائه
الروسي ايضا يقول ان القربى الجغرافيه
والروابط الثقافيه والاقتصاديه وشعبيه
اللغه الروسيه عوامل مشجعه على العيش هنا
استغرقت مساله التاقلم هنا في ارمينيا
شهرين فقط علاقه الارمينيين بالروس جيده
جدا رغم الاحداث الاخيره في شوارعه ريفان
كثيرا ما يبرز الحضور الروسي في هذا البلد
السوفيتي السابق نحو 300 الف روسي يقيمون
اليوم في ارمينيا تشغل الاموال الروسيه
نحو ثلث مجموع الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وتعد
موسكو اكبر شريك تجاري لريفان باكثر من
خمسه مليارات دولار سنويا
السؤال الاهم الى اي مدى نحن بحاجه الى
التخلي عن التعاون مع روسيا اذا كان ذلك
ضروريا فان ارمينيا تحتاج الى عشر سنوات
على الاقل ثم تم معطيات تمثل وفق مراقبين
سيمامه امان لمستقبل العلاقات بين يريفان
وموسكو القاعده العسكريه الروسيه في غمري
واتفاقيات التكامل والدفاع المشترك فضلا
عن قوات حرس الحدود الروسيه المنتشره على
طول حدود ارمينيا مع جيرانها لكن مستقبل
تلك العلاقات في راي كثيرين مفتوح على كل
الاحتمالات في ضوء واقع جيوسياسي اقليمي
يحفل بالمتغيرات
امين ضرغاميه الجزيره هيريفان
[موسيقى]
يتامت الخارجيه الروسيه من سمتهم
اختصاصيين امريكيين وبريطانيين بالتنسيق
مع اوكرانيا في هجومها على مقر الاسطول
الروسي في القرم يوم الجمعه الماضي وعلى
صعيد العمليات العسكريه قال الجيش
الاوكراني انه يواصل تقدمه ويتصدى
لمحاولات هجوميه روسيه على محاور عده في
حين هاجمت القوات الروسيه مستودعه ذخيره
تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه في خرسون جنوبيه
البلاد ومركز تحكم عسكري في مقاطعه دنيا
شرق اوكرانيا
تلتهب المحاور عشرات الاشتباكات القتاليه
خلال ساعات تلك الساعات الافضل بحسب
الاوكرانيين الى تحقيقهم عمليات تقدم
جديده في اقليم دومباس بشرقي البلاد ذكر
مثلا شان محوري ضخمه
يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني فضلا عن ذلك تصديه
لمحاوله هجوميه روسيه على
محورينكا كما يواصل عمليه التمشيط حول
بلده كليشيفكا التي اعاد السيطره عليها
قبل اسبوع من زاويه النظر الاوكرانيه
ستتراء لك انجازات الهجوم المضاد الذي قيل
بشانه الكثير
حتى على مستوى الدفاع ستتبدى انجازات من
نوع اخر
لعل من ذلك حديث الجيش الاوكراني عن تصديه
لعشرات الغارات الجويه والهجمات
بالمقذوفات الصاروخيه التي تستهدف في
الغالب موانئ اوديسا وصوامع تخزين الحبوب
لكن للروس ايضا زاويه ينظرون من خلالها
لمجريات الميدان
ما يسمونها عملياتهم العسكريه في اوكرانيا
لا يعوقها كما يقولون كل المدد العسكري
الذي يتلقاه الطرف الاخر من الغرب
في احداث هجماته استهدف الجيش الروسي مركز
تحكم عسكري في
شرق اوكرانيا
اما هناك جنوبا فهدف هذه المره مستودع
ذخيره تابع للقوات الاوكرانيه في بلده
كيسيليفكا بمقاطعه خرسون غير ان تاثيرات
استمرار الهجمه الاوكرانيه لا سيما
بالطائرات المسيره امر يصعب على موسكو
مداراته هذا جسر القرم الاستراتيجي الذي
تعرض لهجمات اوكرانيه متكرره خلال الشهور
الماضيه
ربما كانت تجدد الهجمات هو ما حمل روسيا
مجددا على تعليق حركه المرور على الجسر
قبل ان تستانفها في وقت لاحق الهجوم
الاخير على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
في سباستوبل هو واحد من الهجمات التي
تعدوها كييف نوعيه يخرج قائد الاسطول
فيكتور سكولف الذي قال الاوكرانيون انه
قتل في الهجوم ليؤكد ان مهام اسطوله تنفذ
بنجاح كما حددتها القياده
اللافت للنظر اكثر ان تخرج موسكو الان
لتوجه اصابع الاتهام الى كل من لندن و
واشنطن
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخارفا قالت ان كيا هاجمت الجمعه الماضيه
مقر الاسطول الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
بالتنسيق مع من سمته مغتصاصيين امريكيين
وبريطانيين
اتهام اخر باثر رجعي تقول موسكو ان واشنطن
ضالعتان بشكل او باخر في تفجير انابيب قبل
نحو عام خط نورت ستريم كما نعلم يعتبر من
اهم المنشات المزوده للطاقه وكان يمد
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه بالغاز
[موسيقى]
الى السودان ففي ضم المعارك المستمره في
انحاء البلاد قالت وزاره الصحه السودانيه
ان الفحص المعملي اكد حدوث وفيات واصابات
بالكوليرا في ولايه القضارف شرقيه السودان
وذلك بعد التعامل مع حالات اشتباه بلغت
265 اصابه وثماني عشره وفاه
احتواء اثار الحرب في السودان ما زال مجرد
عنوان عام
فالتدهر تجاوز الاوضاع الامنيه لفئات
السودانيين كافه
الاطفال بشكل خاص هي الفئه الاكثر هشاشه
فالحرب شردت كثيرين منهم وجعلتهم عرضه
للجوع والامراض والنزوح الى مختلف مدن
السودان هنا في مركز للرعايه الصحيه
بمدينه القضارف
تبحث حليمه عن علاج لطفلتها بعد ان بدا
وزنها في التناقص يوما بعد يوم وعقبا
اجراء الفحوصات الاوليه تاكد لها ان
ابنتها تعاني سوءا في التغذيه
اول مره
ساعدني عشان
بلغ عدد مراجعي هذا المركز اكثر من الف
طفل شهريا معظمهم يعانون سوءا في التغذيه
في مستشفى القضارف للاطفال
تكدس الاطفال المرضى ومن اسعفه الحظ في
الوصول الى طبيب وجد ان الطبيب يحتاج الى
من يزعفه
بالامكانيات الطبيه
[موسيقى]
قاعدين قلنا بيلاقي هنا
واحد
وفقا لمستشفى الاطفال توفي اكثر من 130
طفلا بسبب امراض مختلفه ابرزها سوء
التغذيه والاسهال ونقص الادويه صراحه
الوضع في المستشفى
الوضع الصحي نقص في كل مقومات العمليات
الطبيه
نقص في الادويه في الكوادر
ومعينات العمل
الحرب في السودان
حصدت ارواح مئات الاطفال
والملايين منهم في امس الحاجه الى
المساعدات والدعم النفسي منذ اندلاع الحرب
يعيش هؤلاء الاطفال مع ذويهم في مراكز
ايواء تنعدم فيها مقاومات الحياه الكريمه
الفقر كان سابقا فجاتي الحرب لتجعله سابقا
ولاحقا وحادا حتى الموت ومن لم يمت فروحه
تعاني مشاهده افعال القتل وشتى انواع
العنف الطاهره المرضي الجزيره القضارف
قالت اداره امن محافظه ابيان جنوبيه اليمن
ان خمسه جنود قتلوا واصيب ثلاثه في
اشتباكات مع مسلحين وصفتهم بالارهابيين
واوضحت الاداره في بيان ان الاشتباكات
اندلعت امس الثلاثاء خلال حمله امنيه
لتطهير منطقه وادي الرفض اسفلت عن السيطره
على مواقع كثيره تابعه لمن وصفتهم
بالعناصر الارهابيه والحقت بهم خسائر
كبيره في حين توعد مدير امن ابيا ببسط
سيطره قوات الامن على كامل اوديه عمران
والسلاسل الجبليه التابعه لها وتشن قوات
الامن الحكوميه في ابين عمليه عسكريه منذ
اشهر على مواقع مسلحين متهمين بالانتماء
لتنظيم القاعده اسفرت عن مقتل واصابه
العشرات من الطرفين
قال السنه الديمقراطي بنكاردن انه وافق
على تولي رئاسه لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي بعد تنحي السنه رباب
عن هذا المنصب على خلفيه توجيه اتهامات
فيدراليه له بالفساد وتلقي ريشه وقال
كاردن في بيان انه قبل طلب زعيم الاغلبيه
في المجلس شاكشومر تولي هذا المنصب مشيرا
الى ان الامن القومي يواجه تحديات تتطلب
قياده مسؤوله في الكونجرس للعمل مع البيت
الابيض نيابه عن الشعب الامريكي
قررت وكاله غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين الاونروا وتاجيل بدء العام
الدراسي للطلاب الفلسطينيين في منطقه صيدا
جنوبيه لبنان حتى اشعار اخر بسبب تداعيات
الاحداث التي شهدها مخيم عين الحلوى خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وقالت مديره شؤون
الاونروا في لبنان
ان المسلحين مازالوا يسيطرون على المدارس
الثماني في المخيم والتي تعرضت لاضرار
كبيره نتيجه الاشتباكات المسلحه الاخيره
بينما يستمر وجود عائلات نازحه في المدارس
التابعه للوكاله
اشتاقت غزل وسلام وفاطمه للبيت والمدرسه
في مخيم عين الحلوه هناك تركنا كل شيء قبل
اسابيع كان المفروض انه بس نكون بالمدرسه
ونجحنا تحت نار المعارك الى احدى مدارس
الاونروا في صيدا كلهن امل الا تطول
الاقامه هنا
[موسيقى]
نرجع على البيت ونكمل حياتنا عادي سنه من
حياتنا تروح على الفاضي حرام ونحن
كفلسطينيين اصلا بنات فلسطينيين ما ما في
شيء بيفيدنا غير علمنا
غير علمنا
وبيوتنا وكل شيء راح يعني
رغم عوده الهدوء بعد وقف اطلاق النار لم
يعد 100 لاجئين الفلسطينيين الى مخيم عين
الحلو بعد مراره اللجوء فقامها نزوح فرضته
للشبكات الاخيره التي دمرت ارزاقهم
وتركتهم دون ما لكن بقائهم القصريه هنا
وفق الاونروا يحول دون بدء العام الدراسي
لالاف الطلاب الفلسطينيين ممن تحولت
مدارسهم الى مراكز ايواء عدم وجود مدارس
كافيه داخل المخيم اللي هي مشغوله من قبل
المسلحين وخارج المخيم اللي هي مشغوله من
المنازحين وتقوم الانور باستكشاف السبل
الكفيله بانقاذ العام الدراسي ان كان عن
طريق
استئجار مباني مؤقته او استحداث غرف مسبقه
الصنع وزاد من صعوبه الوضع بلوغ المدارس
خارج المخيم طاقتها الاستيعابيه القصوى
معارك مخيم عين الحلوه لم تلقي بتداعياتها
على المدارس المجاوره لهو حسب فالمدارس
داخل المخيم نالت النصيب الاكبر بعدما
حولها المسلحون الى مواقع محصنه لهم منذ
نحو شهرين
مع بدر الاشتباكات نهايه يوليو الماضي
تمركز مسلحون في ثماني مدارس للاندروه
توفر التعليم لالاف الطلاب داخل المخيم
وتقول الانجوا ان مسح الدمار والاضرار
التي لحقت بالمدارس لن يكون ممكنا قبل
اخلائها من المسلحين وفق ما نص عليه اتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار لابد من اتخذت خطوات
عمليه كي تتحول هذه الهدنه الى اتفاق شامل
وقف اطلاق النار لابد من انسحاب المسلحين
من المدارس وبدء العام الدراسي هذا يعطي
مؤشر اجابه القوى الامنيه المشتركه لابد
ان تاخذ دورها والانتشار في اماكن التوتر
الهدوء هنا اذا لا يزالوها الشن والى ان
تتم معالجه اسباب الاشتباكات وتداعياتها
سيبقى اللاجئون من ابناء هذا المخيم
واطفالهم نازحين بانتظار حل شامل يجنبهم
نكبه جديده كما يقولون كاترين حنا الجزيره
من محيط مخيم عين الحلوه جنوبيه لبنان
[موسيقى]
زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي لدول افريقيه
ستكون محور فقره في المتابعه في حصاد
الليله حيث تتزامن الجوله مع انسحاب فرنسا
عسكريا من القاره ومع مساء روسيه وصينيه
لملا الفراغ هناك سهل اوستن جولته من
كينيا الواقعه في شرق افريقيا لتعزيز
شراكه الامنيه والعسكريه حيث تحتفظ
الولايات المتحده بوجود عسكري قوامه قاعده
سيمبا في خليج ماندا الاستراتيجي المتاخم
للحدود مع الصومال المحطه الثانيه في
زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي كانت جيبوتي
التي تحتضن معسكر لمونير اكبر قاعده
عسكريه امريكيه في افريقيا باكثر من خمسه
الاف بين جنود ومتعاقدين مع البنتاجون
وتمنح هذه القاعده التي تعد نقطه انطلاق
للعمليات الخاصه في انحاء افريقيا تمنح
الجيش الامريكي وضعا استراتيجيا لمواجهه
الجماعات المسلحه والنفوذ المتصاعد لروسيا
والصين وستكون انجولا على الساحل الغربي
لافريقيا المحطه الاخيره في جوله اوستن
حيث يبحث مع مسؤولين في لندن تقويه
العلاقات الدفاعيه وسبل زياده التعاون
العسكري بين البلدين وتاتي هذه الجوله بعد
اعلان الجيش الامريكي اعاده تمركز قوته في
النيجر كاجراء احترازي وعددها نحو
1200 عسكري تم نقلهم من العاصمه الى قاعده
جويه في منطقه اغاديز شمالا الوجود
العسكري الامريكي في القاره الافريقيه
قديم وواسع وقد سجل تطورا نوعيا قبل 15
عاما بانشاء القياده العسكريه الامريكيه
في افريقيا المعروفه اختصارا بافرقه
هي قوات موحده مقاتله تحت اداره وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه وقد بدات نشاطها رسميا
في اكتوبر عام 2008 وهي المسؤوله عن
علاقات الشراكه والعمليات العسكريه مع 53
دوله افريقيه ما عدا مصر التي تقع في نطاق
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه يبلغ عدد
القوات الامريكيه في افريقيا نحو
7500 عسكري يعمل معظمهم من المعسكري في
جيبوتي للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من واشنطن السفير ديفيد شن مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون افريقيا
سيد الوزير ديفيد شان ما الرسائل التي
اراد اوستن ان يوجهها لاسيما حديثه عن
ضروره سياده القانون في افريقيا في اطار
حديثه عن الانق لابات التي تشهدها القاره
المكان لديه سلسله من الرسائل التي وجهها
للفرقاء المختلفين بالنسبه الى الاوضاع في
افريقيا على سبيل المثال كان هناك زياره
للقوات الامريكيه وتركيزه في كينيا كانت
تركيز على مكافحه الارهاب في القرن
الافريقي وايضا يشكر السلطات الدينيه
للمساعده في مهمه خفض السلام اما بالنسبه
الى انغولا هناك نظر في امكانيه التعاون
عن كثب مع انغولا على المستوى العسكري حيث
انه ليس حيث لديها علاقات عسكريه مع روسيا
ومع الصين تقليديا ويود ان يحسن العلاقات
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وانجولا اذا بالنسبه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك
اهتمامات مختلفه على مستوى العسكري وعلى
مستوى الانساني وايضا الدعم
للمؤسسات المدنيه وليس للمؤسسات العسكريه
التي تصل الى السلطه عبر الانقلابات هو لم
يحدد اي بلد على وجه الخصوص ولكنه اوضح ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تحدد فكره
الانقلابات العسكريه فعلا هو قال هذا
الكلام ولكنه ايضا فيما يتعلق بالنيجر
تحدث عن ان الولايات المتحده تريد حلول
ديبلوماسيه ما هي هذه الحلول التي تسعى
اليها فيما يتعلق بالنيجر
هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه وهو سؤال يتبادر الى
ذهن الجميع المشكله بالنسبه الى النيجر هي
انه لدينا 1100 جندي امريكي هناك يشاركون
في عمليات مكافحه للارهاب
ومعظمهم في الجزء الشمالي من البلاد وتود
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تستمر في
جهود مكافحه الارهاب وخصوصا مع التعاون مع
الجيش في النيجر ولكن في الوقت نفسه نحن
راينا ان الجيش انقلب على حكومه ديمقراطيه
مدنيه وتصر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
على اطلاق سراح الرئيس بازوم من اسره هذا
تحدد اساسي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تتعامل مع هذه المعضله حيث ان المصالح
المختلفه تتداخل في هذا البلد والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تسلط ضوء على اهميه
الحل الدبلوماسي ولكنها تجهل ماهيه هذا
الحل
في سبيل الاستمرار فيما وصفته بمكافحه
الارهاب وهذه الاولويه لديها هي على
استعداد للتعامل مع السلطات الانقلابيه في
النيجر في هذا المجال
رغم عدم تلبيه مطلبها باطلاق الرئيس
المتاح به
لا يمكنني ان استثني هذا الاحتمال ولكن
يبدو ان الامور لا تتجه بهذا الاتجاه في
الوقت الراهن القوات الامريكيه المتواجده
في البلاد لا تزال منخرطه في بعض العمليات
ولكنها ليست بشكل تقليدي هي لا تقوم
بالعمليات التقليديه وحصل اعاده انتشار في
البلاد ومن غير الواضح ما الذي سوف تؤول
اليه الامور في المستقبل اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سوف تصر على
ضروره اطلاق سراح الرئيس بازون كحد ادنى
لكن ما خياراتها ان لم يتم تلبيه هذا
المطلب بالنسبه لي دورها
ونفوذها في النيجر
الخيارات ليست جيده في حقيقه الامر في حال
لم يتم تلبيه هذا الطلب يستمر المازق
بكلمات اخرى الوضع على ما هو عليه الان
يطول ولا ربما تستمر هذه الحاله لسبيع
اضافيه نامل ان يتم التوصل الى فهم افضل
ربما على سبيل المثال
بمشاركه من بلدان المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول الغربي افريقيا
للمساعده في النيجر هناك حاجه لتغيير
الترتيبات الحاليه ولكن الوضع يلفه الغموض
شكرا جزيلا لك السفير ديفيد مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون افريقيا
كنت ضيفنا من واشنط
مشاهدينا بهذا نصل الى نهايه حصاد هذه
الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم وتصبحون على
[موسيقى]